lt ragazzi minuti questo nuovo video
sono qua vj ma oggi siamo tornati su air
france non location e figo quando parlo
in inglese mi limone ray da solo va beh
non mi rompete il cazzo che sono tutto
felice problema finché non sento la
musica la musichetta in teoria no non
c'è nessuno nella tua stanza 6
tranquilla zia quanto tempo fate grossa
sostanza ma lui sta gattonando no io
franco benedetto che gioco di merda
c è veramente c'è chi in crisi e songs è
diverso dagli altri c'è pure una presa
per il culo ma quant'è bello ragazzi su
cartone che ogni volta va in onda è
stupendo non so se la parte più bella di
sto gioco e mangiarsi pop corn a capire
perché sto tizio continua a tornare al
lavoro giorno dopo giorno un [ __ ] di
deficiente
però se con lo stipendio riesce a
pagarsi percorrono niente male ragazzi
l'importante che non muoia rischiare la
morte ogni giorno e l'infarto
soprattutto merita i pop corn web con
ben 9 ma non vedevo l'ora zero chiude
che ha sponsor ce l'hai l'ecm apple
quicktime qtv qualcosa mi dice che non
funzionerà la tastiera voce scopre si
dimentichi per insomma fatta meccanico o
del prete fu il vecchio forse leiten
caio bongos casual bongos
ma cos'è sta merci sarei proprio tutto
il giorno ad ascoltare sti casual bongo
se però mi sa che devo andare avanti pro
grazie per averli messi proprio me
meglio di martin garics basta se mi fai
cliccare grazie gentilissimo un'ora e
mezza e là c'è qui va bene dove la tipa
cosa che mi premeva dato il consiglio
perché tutto buio
no a rega dai michia perché tutto buio
mi fate duramente posso torna indietro
perché posso entrare la fox he adesso
qual è il problema posso entrare da fox
ma entriamo da fox in va bene ma io non
vedo niente c'è il gioco di merda ma per
quale motivo ma perché deve essere tutto
quando la mia il sensore qualcosa poi mi
chiami
[Musica]
l'unico modo che ho per vedere veramente
questo ci arrivi e non ci arrivi o se
cazzo di camera ok io non ci sto
arrivando e fermi fi che ci sono
arrivato in out our way shake your già
magis debolissimo ecc fate ces che aprì
smog ed aironi on the sirens chiama
change.org racing france network
facebook eight smoke free space
giostrando lisma dobric il pres
questo great thou blocchetto giulio
smart chic imprese
ok questo non che facebook è ben presto
ban next faris why aye nokia football
che presto banjos dopo ferries non so
che a [ __ ] va a farmi a the face
playstation neo bio per buche and press
mobius air race kinder scavato gioco di
merda cosa devo fare non ho sentito ex
one touch screen should not be open è
quella ormai francesca per quei razzi
you on air obliqua youtube maggio
ma non c'è chi aspetta dove bagni
non ce l'ho fatta porca eva manova non
posso per star lì dove sto andando le
che affermi cos'è questa roba non poteva
essere tutto così il gioco sarebbe stato
molto più bello ma tanto avrei
apprezzato molto di più mag
[Musica]
peccato io ci kredevo davvero
va bene [ __ ] tua sorella è pure
tutti e due si sono aperte ma non ci
torno lì dentro talmacsi hun whiteboard
fonte è sbagliato non dovevo correre
all'inizio ma l'ho dimenticato sorry ok
ragazzi siamo tornati i mobbers set
calato di nuovo lo sapevo pure due già
del face place cernobbio per luca and
press mobile ora il problema e per marca
e va così difficile
porco e lo 0 0 guarda sono convinto di
tornare domani grazie
vado via bene che bello il mio lavoro
avo il mio lavoro bellissimo modo torna
tutti indietro e ci sta pure tizio che
bastardo pure perché lo sento chi si
muove c'è il massimo della vita che vedo
chance con cui mi diceva bene è finito
il tuo lavoro poi tornare domani
convinto che io torni domani no però ci
tornerò che tanto va a capire che
problemi
[Musica]
ok
sono controllo padre perché cos'è sta
roba
cos'è mister pensi in frac white grazie
[Musica]
qui doveva andare così pezzi di merda un
infarto ral obbligatorio grazie
lei mi ha coperto chi l italia
aimone conti kicker
ok ben più allora ok se non avrò mi stai
a fa scendere valle che con la nuova
vita io che te keeping con scenari
in forno letica il primo appuntamento ti
raccontano tutti loro volta è andato via
[Musica]
quanto bordello finché neanche quando i
vicini attaccano i quali ricerche un
bordello legato
[Musica]
ok per quello che dovrebbe ok wow bene
quando finita di attaccare il quadro
infatti sapere niente
credo sia a posto che bello tra l'altro
uno più bello e importante
le equazioni
[Musica]
cioè lei mi ha tenuto
mi scusi si è rotta si è rotto va bene
come sono dentro facebook
no no no no no no non lo fa in più anni
che non andava bene prima mentre il kit
non devo non ho capito cosa ha detto
qualcosa sul mio battito cardiaco e
scorreva [ __ ]
cos'hai destra non ho capito farmaco non
capisce una cosa muore perché non sa
cosa deve fare grazie ad ottenere queste
cose su gli springboks chi l'aveva
capito
ok che il limite già me la cavo ma non
così tanto
ah ok ho capito prima
se ritengo su loro non li ripara nomali
riparo io ok capace non so capace e
[ __ ]
non so che faceva bene ok questo un
problema suicidarmi
fatemi suicidare porca eva nervoso ti su
tutti su effetto letto perfetto perfetto
vai bye bye bye bye ok abbastanza easy
adesso aiuto cosa cazzo devo fare a
questo punto qualcuno me lo spiega
perché porca di una [ __ ] eva non è
quello che mi dice lei ma ci sono anche
sopra minchia quanti sono e problemi ai
ragazzi stata non so non ho capito cosa
vista devo fare spiegatemelo no anzi
capisce un cazzo vabbè con quello via
episodio ragazzi ho bisogno vostro aiuto
ragazzi nei commenti chiedete anche alla
nonna cosa devo fare io aiuto perché
venisse faceto ragazzi conclude episodio
e cose di più sul momento è un mi piace
anche a pace di facebook e cavani di
sottoscrizione sensore city sky principi
piano fosse un lido 0 ragazzi